whose idea was it to for you guys to
audition for this we were we were 14
when we first auditioned and we we
learned about it because my mum's friend
got in touch with her so you get like a
raffle ticket obviously when your raffle
when your numbers could you go and then
we stood down after about 20 minutes or
so I couldn't even realize that we all
realized that we were the only set of
identical twins who weren't wearing the
same clothes which in hindsight you
think yeah you need to look the same you
go dressed the same but this is how
green we were to be the whole process so
we we darted across to the department
store over the road and then bought just
matching shirts
and yeah and then we we eventually got
seen probably about three hours later or
so I think a couple days later we got a
a phone call saying yeah we'd love to
see the guys at the main Studio to
France London and we fax you the start
at the side but it's even for email a
longer four emails only available to
everyone so they would practice the uh